l'histoire de l'arboretum est aussi
l'histoire d'un homme philippe andré de
vilmorin fils du marchand greniers du
roy et grands horticulteurs début du 19e
siècle la marine nationale veut
reconstituer rapidement sa flotte perdue
pendant la bataille de trafalgar
vilmorin acquiert alors le domaine des
bars une propriété de 300 hectares il y
plante une forêt expérimentale sur
plusieurs hectares où il compare
rapidité de croissance et résistance de
différentes espèces d'arbres
essentiellement des pins et des chênes
américains
au fil du temps bien d'autres variétés
sont venus enrichir la collection
ouverte au public depuis 1985 pour la
gérer il y à nicolas depuis 15 ans il
entretient renouvelle recherche de
variétés pour enrichir laborit à
l'arboretum c'est trois grandes
thématiques donc une première thématique
qu'on appelle ici combien d'alice donc
on ne porte son nom on est les arbres et
arbustes sont classés par origine
géographique
les européens à côté les américains de
los médiatique une deuxième partie qu'on
appelle le blizzard et tom hogan ce
n'est plus une collection horticole les
arbres et arbustes sont classés par port
en fait les pyramides au d'un côté les
arbres en boule de l'autre à feuillage
bleuté et d'oeuvrer ensemble et la
collection dans laquelle on est à
l'heure actuelle on m'appelle classifica
donc tout tout est classé par famille
botanique on retrouve l'année d'enfer et
les glycines on a le carré les érables
carré des frênes voilà ici en classe on
est très cartésien on aime bien tous
placés
non
incite les gens à sortir des sentiers
battus à ne pas suivre on indique
volontairement sur le blond a un sens de
visite pour que les gens aient quelque
chose mais plus ils déambulent dans les
collections plus mieux c'est en fait
pour découvrir ou redécouvrir les
collections au quotidien
oui
on passe un petit coup de tondeuse
toutes les semaines une façon ce qui
fait quand même une zone pour pouvoir se
repérer pas se perdre et après j'irai le
régal c'est de voir les gens qui
reviennent à l'accueil avec le pantalon
mouillé jusqu'au genou on sait qu'ils
sont premiers dans l'est dans les hautes
herbes c'est très intéressant à
découvrir la petite fleur la petite
faune qu'il y en ait qui guident
naturellement
sapin d'espagne séquoia américain jean
cau biloba nous sommes dans la
collection continental is commencé en
1873 ici beaucoup d'arbres sont plus que
centenaires et sont autant de fragments
de paysages venus des cinq continents là
on se situe vraiment au coeur des
vieilles collections en 1873 pour les
premières collections botaniques donc la
fin des années
2000 on a eu un petit coup de vent et ça
a fait tomber pas mal de gros arbres ont
reconstruit derrière et tout l'intérêt
c'est de replanter en espérant que tout
ce que l'on réintroduit dans les
collections puisse donner ces beaux
arbres prédécesseurs nous on essaie
aujourd'hui c'est l'office national des
forêts qui assure la gestion touristique
pédagogique et scientifique de
l'arboretum renommée arbaud faut lire
tout au long des saisons enfants et
adultes sont invités à des ateliers de
découverte où les sens sont mis à
contribution
ici le paysage se voit ce sens s'écoute
et parfois même se goûte
tâche est en train de remettre un petit
peu en état le sentier des traces donc
sentier des traces ce groupe là on a une
empreinte de martrin et donc pour que
les visiteurs puissent retrouver en
effet
le sentier donc but de ce sentier c'est
de retrouver une quinzaine d'animaux de
nos forêts là on est un petit peu dans
une ambiance forestière on sait que les
gens ont du mal
a du mal à pénétrer dans la forêt donc
là on essaie de leur faire oublier un
petit peu justement les sentiers on les
fait sortir un petit peu du sentier pour
aller chercher les animaux et tout du
moins les traces d'animaux
voilà il ya un aspect pédagogique de
réappropriation de nature on va dire
éveillez faire découvrir avec ses 2600
espèces d'arbres et d'arbustes venus des
cinq continents l'arboretum des bars
vous invite à vous initier un paysage
pluriel